TD Garden Arena in Boston yes for the
Celtics place yeah dude no no no he's
won the base come yeah he's Denis Leary
I'm just saying I'll see after him I'm
like younger than he is yeah so like in
the comedy circle I just heard people
out saying how Jack Bill Hicks that was
so that's up so those people listen man
if Dennis he'd be a great guest on our
show
I'd love I'd love to have a month yeah
he's just amazing I mean I I and by the
way I looked into that Bill Hicks thing
I was there for it I was doing it I I
just don't buy it
there was Bill Hicks had a huge he had a
huge effect and influence on people a
lot of so much yeah so were you so what
happens is you yeah it rubs off you your
food another my best friends are no cure
for cancer my best friends are you to
Lee it like a lot of my mannerisms a
kind of mine are yours right yeah barred
lingo yeah the way I know we all you
know the way I flow if I'm fine I people
see me do someone stays like do That's
So Cal me five percent whatever I think
was my mentor but what I do in I do J
and I do Jimmy Burke you know like you
know die so much of what I was doing was
you know doing Jimmy Jimmy I was like
when I was younger because he was older
and he was New York and I was like [ __ ]
you know that stuff like I'm not hearing
a peep out of him yeah that's Jimmy
yeah you know that stuff Baba that's
Jimmy all that stuff is goes guys those
guys were older than me from New York I
Jimmy I come hide but I stole that [ __ ]
and then now you know it's what we do
language is passed down from the accents
exact accents come from from listening
to your older of yours after they lie to
be like the frat sense right so you
admire me can on your [ __ ] knees
hey man huh right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]